Ja.
Wenn man sich die heutigen Möglichkeiten anschaut, ist es meiner Meinung nach
auch sehr wichtig zu fragen:
Was ist die Roadmap? Wie viel
leistungsfähiger werden diese Systeme,
und wie viel komplexer
werden die circuits sein, die wir ausführen können?
Dafür haben wir eine sehr wichtige Kennzahl entwickelt,
die sich Quantum Volume nennt.
Manchmal liest oder hört man in der Presse
von der Anzahl der qubits —
als Maß für den Fortschritt.
Ich sage euch ganz direkt:
Die bloße Anzahl der qubits in einem System ist kein
gutes Maß für Fortschritt.
Fortschritt muss daran gemessen werden,
wie komplex der circuit ist, den man ausführen kann.
Qubits und diese Maschinen sind heute noch nicht perfekt.
Sie haben Fehler, die durch die Kopplung des
Systems mit der Außenwelt entstehen.
Genau die Stärke dieser qubits —
Verschränkung und diese besonderen Eigenschaften —
macht sie gleichzeitig leistungsstark
und empfindlich gegenüber Einflüssen
aus der Außenwelt.
Man muss also die Fehlerrate senken,
während man die Anzahl der qubits erhöht.
Das ist es, was hier dargestellt wird.
Was man wirklich anstrebt, ist eine Bewegung entlang der Diagonale.
Quantum Volume ist eine Kennzahl, die
beide Werte und einige weitere wichtige Faktoren vereint.